le moment est solennel presque
douloureux pour la deuxième fois en
moins d'un mois joe biden joue le rôle
du consolateur en chef d'une nation en
deuil à cause de la violence armée
fait quelque chose crie l'un des badauds
nous allons faire quelque chose répond
le président dont le pouvoir de changer
les lois en la matière est somme toute
assez limité
la visite de joe biden est bien vue par
ceux qui espèrent malgré tout que les
lois sur le contrôle des armes à feu
soit renforcée
il faut relever l'âge minimum de 18 à 21
explique monica gutiérrez pour acheter
les carabines
vous pouvez acheter ses armes chez
wal-mart dit véronique mendes c'est
insensé
autant de propositions qui sont sur la
table notamment une loi pour interdire
ces armes d'assaut comme cela a déjà été
le cas pendant dix ans jusqu'en 2004 à
sunderland fait
sénateurs démocrates voient des
ouvertures dans les négociations avec
les républicains
représentant républicain est maintenant
favorable à l'interdiction des armes
d'assaut
certains de ses collègues aussi dit il
mais ils ont peur de le dire ou même de
voter en faveur du projet de loi car ils
craignent la direction de leur parti
on a assez des tergiversations
politiques des républicains
et démocrates ne veulent pas priver les
américains du droit de porter des armes
mais ils veulent juste que des vies ne
soit plus fauché par ces armes à feu en
attendant bien des questions demeurent
sur ce massacre qui n'aurait jamais dû
arriver ici
en plus des enquêtes internes de l'état
du texas le département fédéral de la
justice va aussi mener la sienne sur le
déroulement de l'intervention policière
de mardi dernier une intervention
policière qui du propre aveu des
autorités locales a été très mal gérée
c'est une autre façon de passer au
peigne fin les erreurs commises ici afin
d'éviter d'autres cafouillage dans les
inévitables futur fusillade aux états
unis d'ici frédéric arnould radio canada
où il va dès au texas